Barrett still looking for his first point that
top unit was excellent the other night against
the Canadians across it goes and a little
flip by Samberg in front is denied eers
with a chance and it's handled that time
by Vela here he's a one heck of a player
a lot like Clayton K just so shy save
by Helu first touch of the game for the
Winnipeg Jets golender as it's cleared
out now Jersy freezing KRA now bring it
up and here they come maybe a two-on-one
butelli is in a little feather pass Moser
Stars JJ Moser one [Music] nothing what a play
by JJ Moser and he beats everyone up the ice
look at the pass by Koss look at Moser see you
later Separation on shley Beats him to the front
of the net and Matias melli oh yeah he'll find
you get to the net stick on the ice head up the
entire way look at that saucer pass by melli just
out of the reach of shley and the hands and now
[__] to dery they work it around Keller's got
it Keller across right there oh and [__] fired
it wide him O'Brien right back to the front that
angled off es skate that might have gone off curo
State in front again curo that time just couldn't
get to the loose pot and now Mory holding on to
it morisy back towards the front now back out
High Dello over to Morris he shoots on that one
getting enough of Mela behind find out right now
here's a shot by Morris he lets one go deflected
in front and right off the crest shoulder area
of AA and that's why you hang around the blue
paint Brendan Dylan played in behind
the net for Conor looks to go backand
to the front flew It Away by steter tell
you what simple play by Troy there but
it behind the net NES nikov back to eers O'Neil
pan goes across to the front and the micov can't
finish it out of the zone and all the way back
Brendan Dylan now shley give away here mcmains
got it they score put home Liam O'Brien and it's
two nothing [Music] [Applause] [Music] coyotes
well you make teams pay the Jets have the
pot perfect position shley has it tries to
go right up the gut fam's on the pass McBain
picks it up and lets it Fly and Liam O'Brien
with the second whack at it buries it go to
the blue paint kids at home this is where you
score the goals marone's got it he's got
KY in front oh good stick Mory might have
been Nino Neer Rider as well as this one is
played back in here they come Mory a little
drop Appleton to the front and they score and
that was tipped in by neita ryer and it's a 2-1
game here they come after the coyotes turn the
puck over on the two-on-one zipping it around and
there's the drive to the net by Neer Rider gets
a stick on it beautiful play all the way up back
through Center ice and bringing it in is SCH small
right to the front follow up Miss Hatton he can't
put it home two on coyotes Moser and O'Brien for
petty down to mnov for Winnipeg try to throw it to
the front and they score and they've tied it brend
and Dylan through a a maze of players and it's
2-2 has to be focused on him
here's the pass by nesa coff
and nobody home for the coyotes to pick
up Dylan who sneaks down head up hereas
melli now Smith played around La and
Krauss late in the power play eight
to go melli across one timer stop
rebound they score Lon Krauss oh
you go to the front you pick up the
junk and good things happen Tyson
Picasso the CES they work the boards big bukes
that in front and Lawson cruss back door front
of the net excuse me there's the initial shot by
carcone big juicy rebound comes right to Krauss
who's got the hot stick we talked about it scores
and bunches the big man that is a huge huge goal
for this coyotes group eers Nikolai eers back
out High across SMI partially fanned on theer
Rider goes after it and now smid back out High
across for eers to the front they score Neer
Rider now the Jets have found something and
it's a 33 game real good Movement we talked
about it on their first Power Play zipping it
around and that puck gets tossed in the net eers
for one reason he knows Neer Rider's going there
durit can't pick up the stick little backhander
through the front shley again and eers rips one
wide a rebound conter was there tried to play it
off the end boards what a save by caraa score on
the power play looking for the go-ahead goal here
Connor gets a gift right off the Stick of carala
Mala almost into the back of the net boom left
pad ban will get it out M coyot will bring it
along play right to the line sha dery across
and a pad save Bo is laboring gusterson's got it
right to the front steered away off the Stick of
AA power he holds on to it good line out there
right now for the Jets here's a chance Appleton
back out High Dylan takes a shot he scores post
it in Brendan Dylan it's 4-3 Winnipeg they have
the puck and they flip it right back to the the
Jets in the neutral zone and they come back and
stick it right in their net teraa almost
had this one that's a absolute bom from CL
assist2 Appleton picks up an
assist here's another shot off
the pipe this is momentum right here now the Jets
buzzing D are going to try to chase it down Dylan
is there he'll play it in behind the neck back
out High it goes Dylan towards the front it's
underneath and they score poked home that's Neer
Rider I I believe yeah that's that's going to be
the hat trick for neita Rider and again this is
what this line does works it down low pops it
up High Here Comes the shot the redirection by
Lowry and that puck was just sitting behind Carell
Vela who thought he had it and Neer Rider what a
night for [Applause] him as he buries his third
of the hockey game and fifth now of the Season
Hatton to shoot the puck here Keller now back out
High bounces in front and ripped wide by cross
Jersey's going to bring it out cleared out and
that's going to do it here this afternoon as all
the way back to get it is Kyle Conor he wants
the goal as the horn sounds he won't get it